all right welcome to part 2 of the 6x6
tutorial at this point you should have
your black and your yellow 4x4 centers
completed and directly opposite each
other I'm going to be placing them on
the left and the right sides of the cube
so that we don't break them up when
we're placing the remaining 4 centers
the next two centers we will place will
be adjacent or directly next to each
other for demonstration I will place the
red and the blue Center however you can
place other colors as long as you place
them in the proper orientation a good
way to determine what the proper
orientation is is to look at the corners
of the cube as you'll see if black goes
here then blue must go here and red must
go here so red black and blue are always
in a clockwise orientation you can also
do the blue orange and yellow center
orientation this is known as the boy
orientation these moves to create
centers should be more familiar to you
now as you continue solving the center's
you'll notice that the center pieces
will begin to group together more I'd
like to spend more time on the last two
centers which are trickier to place so
I'm going to go a little faster when
placing the red and the blue centers
since we already have three pieces here
let's continue to solve the red center
next it can go in any position that we
like okay so what we could do is bring
this piece down now we have 1 1 by 4
block okay
we could bring this piece up so that
it's on the same layer as this one when
we do that we're going to disrupt this
so up flip it vertical and bring it back
down now all we need to do is to get a
piece there bring it up flip it vertical
and then bring that layer back now we
could join this cheese to that piece by
flipping them both vertical okay so we
have two pieces here so we'll put them
horizontal get this piece down flip it
down flip that vertical and then flip it
back put this horizontal and we can get
this piece over there
flip it down vertical and put this back
now we could bring this 1 by 4 block
next to these two you flip these two
around and then we flip this all the way
around to join it to those two now we
just need one more okay so we have these
two pieces here and we also have those
two pieces here so what we can do is we
could bring these two pieces down to
that face flip them that way and then
bring it back now we'll put these two on
the bottom and flip this one up flip it
vertical and then flip that layer back
put the stack horizontal put this piece
down there ring 3 bring back to put this
vertical and then bring that layer back
now we created our last 1 by 4 block and
we just put it around and we have
completed the read Center all right so
now that we have the read center
complete we need to place the blue
Center next to it if you remember me
explaining the red the black and the
blue are in a clockwise orientation if
you look at the corner piece here the
black is matched the red is matched the
blue must be placed here all right so
let's go on to place the blue we have
three pieces here join this piece up
flip it up vertical down look again we
have three pieces here so bring this
piece flip it up vertical and flip that
layer back now we could join this piece
to this piece
kick it out turn it twice bring it back
okay so we have two pieces here and we
have two pieces here so we could bring
both of these up turn this vertical
bring this one down and then bring this
one down now we could join this piece up
to these two so we turn it around 180
degrees remember this messes up the red
so we turn this twice and then turn it
around twice again now we just need one
more Center so we have these two pieces
and
two pieces okay so let's bring these two
pieces off of this face so we could work
with it flip it around twice and then
bring that back okay so now we need to
place these two pieces in these spots so
we could bring this one down flip this
vertical and then bring this back now
this piece needs to go here so we'll
bring it off of that face put it up
there
bring this down with this vertical and
then bring that face back so that we
reform the red Center all right so now
we just need to get this onto the blue
side so we twist this around now we have
to kick out this end spot so we twist it
around turn the top twice and then flip
this around twice so now if you take a
look the red the black and the blue
should be in a clockwise orientation at
this point you should have four centers
completely solved and properly oriented
so just double check to make sure that
opposite of black you have yellow and
the red black and blue centers are in a
clockwise orientation if your centers
are not properly oriented you must fix
them first before continuing to place
the remaining two centers which in my
case are the green and the orange
centers we're going to be using similar
moves however I'm also going to teach
you a helpful algorithm which can be
used at any time to switch identical
center pieces what we're going to do
first is to focus on solving one center
and try to get as many pieces on to
their proper side as possible this is
because if we solve one center then the
other center will be solved as well so
we must determine where the last two
centers will go so opposite of red needs
to go orange and opposite of blue needs
to go green so this is going to be the
green and this is going to be the orange
center all right so we know that this is
going to be the orange side and this is
going to be the green side knowing that
let's take a look and see what we have
do we have any one by four blocks
already solve for us in my case I don't
have any
one by four blocks but you may if you do
that's the center you're going to want
to try to solve okay so let's take a
look at what I have I have three pieces
here I have three pieces here so I'm
going to try to solve the orange center
so what I want to do is I have a corner
piece here I could bring it up to join
with these three so when I bring it up
I'll bring this vertical and then I'll
bring this back down now what that has
done is it actually created another 1 by
4 block so let me bring this one by 4
block next to this one since this is
going to be the orange side I'll flip
this vertical I'm going to kick this out
turn the top twice and bring this back
alright so now what you see is that I
have two pieces here I have three here
and I have three here also if you look
at it like that so what you can do now
if you're confused and you don't know
what to join together what you could do
is take what you have already and try to
just put it on to the proper side so we
know that this is going to be the orange
side I have three pieces here now I
might not be able to get another piece
there but what I could do is I could
kick out this piece and that way I'll
bring this back on to the green side so
what you do is you turn this around I'm
going to kick out this piece so I'll
kick that out turn the top around twice
and then bring this back so now we have
just added this on to this orange side
all right so now what we could do
you really can't join this piece up to
anything very well it's not going to
form any 1 by 4 block but what you could
do is you'll see that you already have
three so what you can do is you can also
kick out the end piece here
that way we can bring these three green
pieces onto the green side so what you
do is you turn this vertical and then I
want to kick out this end piece so I'll
turn the end so that's aligned with this
one and now I'll bring this up turn the
top twice
and then bring this down so now you'll
see I only have two centerpieces left so
what you want to first do is basically
just try to create those 1 by 4 blocks
if you can't create anymore just start
kicking out pieces which have less than
the ones that you're kicking it out with
that way you can bring as many pieces
onto the proper side as possible then
you can go on to learn the algorithm
which I'm going to teach you now all
right so what you should have done at
this point is placed as many center
pieces onto their proper side as
possible the move I'm about to show you
will switch any identical center pieces
because this move may involve different
layers I found it easier to remember it
as a sentence the sentence is down over
down over up over up over it's really
not that hard to memorize
however write it down and I'm going to
explain exactly what it means now what
you want to do is put the two pieces you
want to switch in the same relative
position so I have a right edge center
piece here and I have another right edge
center piece here this orange one needs
to go here and the green one needs to go
here so I prefer to put the pieces in
the upper left of the 4x4 Center so
they're both in the upper left then what
you do is you bring the top one down to
kick out the one on the front so this
goes down just that one piece now you'll
see this piece is here we bring it over
by turning this face clockwise so down
and then over now the piece is on the
right layer here so this face goes down
and then we bring this face over or
counterclockwise this time now we bring
this layer which we initially brought
down we bring it up so this goes up and
then we bring this face again over or
clockwise and now this layer goes up and
we have basically switched them but we
have to also turn this face over
counterclockwise to bring it back the
way it was initially
all right so that switch those two
pieces to switch these two pieces we
also we can get them in the upper left
so I'll put that in the upper left and
put this one in the same relative
position then to switch it remember it's
down over down over up over up over so
down now this piece goes over now it's
on this layer so this layer goes down
and then this goes over or
counterclockwise now this face which we
initially brought down goes up and now
this face goes over or clockwise now
this face goes up and you would turn it
over if you were switching more pieces
but as you'll see we have completed the
last two centers so right that algorithm
down and it should help you switch any
two centers that you need to switch